welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 15. first
a quick shout out to this video's
sponsor the amc the walking dead shop
that's where you can get some super
sweet official the walking dead merch
and stay tuned after the recap as i
unbox one of their supply drop
subscription boxes it's gonna be fun so
episode 15 begins at the apartment
complex where lance hornsby is
investigating what happened here aaron
and gabriel don't want to let on they
found out about lance hornsby's secret
mission in case he you know has them
killed so their story is the apartment
people attacked and they're conveniently
the only survivors lance hornsby's a
smart guy he knows they're lying but
he's staying friendly for now but he's
not letting it go if these dangerous
apartment killers are on the loose
they'd better go warn hilltop on the way
they run into some walkers and while the
stakes aren't very high our crew gets to
prove that they are awesome expert
zombie killers some of the coolest kills
yet but now they get to hilltop where
lance hornsby's like hey we're friends
just let us in to look around but
maggie's like i don't think so and so
we've made it to the flash forward scene
where daryl takes off his stormtrooper
helmet at the time it seemed like it was
a daryl maggie war but now we see
daryl's on her side like hey let us in
so this doesn't turn violent so lance
hornsby continues to act casual but he
knows maggie's hiding something in fact
he finds the truck that he sure was at
the scene but he can't prove anything so
for now we're still friends meanwhile
back at the commonwealth the rest of our
crew was also working to expose the
dirty secrets of sebastian milton
sending people to their deaths rosita
told eugene and now they bring in
reporters connie and kelly remember
someone slipped them a mysterious list
of names and it's like yeah that girl
was one of the ones sent but not all
these people this is something else they
ultimately realize to uncover this
conspiracy they need someone with inside
access to the miltons and eugene knows
someone his girlfriend max he tries to
bring her in on it but at first she's
like yo this is way too dangerous but
now she goes to her brother mercer who's
getting a workout in so he has an excuse
to show off these muscles by the way
here we learn that his first name is
mike and also he and princess are
confirmed getting it on but now mike and
max mercer get to talking about the
sebastian thing and mercer's like look
this place isn't perfect but it's the
best we got to keep the commonwealth
together and 50 000 people safe it's
just what we'll have to live with but
max doesn't feel good about it and she's
like yo bro you can be much more than
the general who just follows orders so
the seeds are planted for mercer to rise
up and do a military coup but i mean you
know a good one and max goes back to
eugene like hey you know what i'm in
it's time to stand up for what's right
i'll steal whatever of pamela milton's
papers can help eugene says some sweet
romantic things to her and so it's time
these two dorks kiss there's also a
subplot in this episode ezekiel goes to
yumiko's brother like hey i need your
help to do an off-the-book surgery
there's a veterinarian who's been
helping people that can't afford a human
doctor but now one patient could really
use some help and i mean this just takes
up a lot of screen time the one nice
part though is that ezekiel and carol
get to spend some more time together
really bond again she's like hey we're
still not getting back together
romantically but he's like you know i
bet we will but now back at hilltop
lance hornsby find someone else to
interrogate maggie's son herschel little
herschel's faced worse than lance
hornsby in his life he doesn't crack but
lance hornsby has the hat he left like
oh look at that perfect fit but elijah
busts in like yo you leave the kid out
of it and oh oh now everyone's on high
alert guns drawn all around daryl who
for some reason was allowed to just
fully take off all his stormtrooper
armor is now clearly on maggie's side
he's like yohorn's be tell your men to
put their guns down before something
really bad happens and he's so serious
he drops one of the walking dead's rare
f-bombs lance isn't ready to make a big
scene here especially i think he doesn't
want to die so he's still in friendly
mode like hey sorry maggie like we'll
just leave but that night at camp his
men have found something and indeed
nearby is leah with the stolen
commonwealth guns they try to sneak up
on her but leah's too good for that
starts taking him out lance is like hey
we just want to talk so leah comes to
hear him out and he's like i want to
offer you a job so we're building up to
a climax here as we go into episode 16
the mid-season finale of this part two
of three of the final season all of our
characters are now entangled in the
shady underbelly of the commonwealth who
will survive the coming confrontation
find out on the next episode of the
walking dead welcome to the man of
recaps his living room i'm here with the
walking dead supply drop subscription
box we're going to open this thing up
and see what's inside remember you can
get this at the amc the walking dead
universe shop link in the description
they've got awesome official the walking
dead merch and best thing of all are the
supply drop subscription boxes they send
you one every quarter with all sorts of
cool goodies inside you don't know what
you're gonna get this one's awesome here
they got mercer poster right on the
front and this one's all decorated in
like the commonwealth stuff okay here we
go can i open it on my first try like
super smoothly oh i did it oh man okay
here we go you guys get to see what's
happening on the inside first things
first we've got
a sweatshirt oh man this thing's comfy i
like it and we got the cool full
commonwealth logo on the back so you
know
baller yeah this is my new go-to
sweatshirt uh my girlfriend likes to set
the ac down super low in the summer so
i'm gonna have to wear this all summer
long hilariously and that's all for this
week we're splitting it up because i'm
gonna do the rest of this box in next
week's recap episode 16 the mid-season
finale sign up now while quarter one is
still going so you make sure you get all
this stuff so that way end of the year
you've got the full package of
exclusives the links in the description
to make it real easy for you so this is
super cool and thanks for unboxing with
me
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and news
[Music]